i'm just i'm delighted to be here this
evening with you guys and meet you for
the first time i really am and i'm
looking forward to working with you
because on the outside we are so
different that so many of us in so many
ways are different
different cultures different i mean
there's people here from other countries
right are there not
right yeah right
uh
and yet on the inside we are all so
similar and it is those similarities
that bring us here to this room
together right
um
we feel
too much and too deeply
and we wound too easily
we seek out a lot of time alone
that we tend to enjoy and that makes
other people think we're pretty weird
and all of us are obsessive compulsives
are we not
or we wouldn't have chosen
you know be drawn to the work that we do
[Music]
but anyway i am looking very much
forward to it
and thanks you know for being here and
being on time and all that stuff
uh i really appreciate it but i would
like to introduce our guests here
karen and david are collectively
an incredibly fine youtube channel
called film courage
have any of you ever been there or seen
it right film courage
i just i just checked guys and they now
have over 200 000
subscribers
roaring on their way to a quarter of a
million and that is a bloody remarkable
and what they are doing just you know as
an academic and all that stuff
they are creating a library
of our time
that you just kind of happened into to
hear the way you began anyway right
they're creating this library of our
time here this slice of life
on planet earth
in the in a look into the creativity
and just plain hard work
of film and tv
um that's what they're doing they're all
these interviews and now sometimes you
know classes like this one will be
uh it's i have a feeling it's going to
be like samuel
is peeps diary
you know what anybody know what that is
oh they're too obscure okay
it was samuel peeps was a guy in
the mid 1600s
in london who was a compulsive diarist
and every day he wrote until
an entire bookshelf ultimately
with you know 12 volumes or however many
it is but what he was doing was
recording and he loved theater
he absolutely loved it and he's got
every detail of all the shows and the
plots and what went on what people
looked like it's all there and it is a
treasure trove
of uh for academics
now to look back and really see and
understand what life was like then and
what theater was like
and that's what you guys are doing
whether you know it yet or not
okay
my first task here as a class
overall is
do what i can to get us all on the same
page
this is a room
full of talent and talented people
but
the experience of that talent as it
ranges it ranges from
to the to the end of near novice or just
getting started
to
working professional screenwriters
they're all here
and what i'm going to show you here
the journey we're going to take through
through screen story structure
is uh
can be looked at several ways for some
of you it'll be new stuff for all of you
i've got something new don't worry about
that
but for some of you there'll be a lot of
new stuff and for some of you it will be
review
right
but there is another way of looking at
it too you guys are proposing and are
pursuing to get your mfa
in screenwriting and a master of fine
art a 42-unit degree master of fine arts
is what is called
a terminal degree
and that means in that field
beyond that degree there is nothing no
other degree that's higher than
and that means as many of you know the
master of fine arts and screenwriting is
a kind of a license
to teach
in every college and every university
not only in the united states of america
but also generally in the
world and that's something worth having
i mean i was doing that when i was a kid
and i was i didn't want to leave college
i just loved it too much and the world
was scary and i early on i was getting
this stuff and i got these degrees
and then life rolled on and i just stuck
them in a drawer and then a time came
when
you know an offer came
and i was qualified i had this stuff
so these this is this is a can be a
powerful and important degree to you
really
so and and therefore since you're
putting the possibility of teaching in
your closet stashing it away somewhere
another way to look at everything you
see us do uh your instructors your
mentors here for the next two years
you it can become a study in how certain
things are taught each of us is
different and each of us has a certain
different approach
right but um
pay attention
all the hand i'm going to have i'm a
handout person and you'll get them as we
go forward save your handouts
have these notebooks for yourself for
each topic
because the day may very well come and i
think it will for many if not most of
you
when you will be teaching and you will
have this reference material right there
and you won't have to be starting from
scratch
okay
brace yourselves uh
i am going to be pursuing
and showing mostly not all but mostly
mainstream
commercial hollywood
well one hero we'll talk about that
later
motion pictures
that were huge hits at the box office
worldwide
that is what we're going to be
discussing
and the only reason
that a huge box office you know that
the size of the box office that the
amount of money any particular movie
made
the only reason that's important for us
is that it tells us these were effective
emotional undertakings that touched the
hearts
of millions of people all over the world
and that's what we're going for
what we do
is emotional what we do is convey
emotion to an audience
because that's what they have come to
experience
you go to the movies to feel deeply and
so we'll look at
how you cause that to be how you bring
that about okay
first things first
historical perspective
once upon a time
long ago
there was
a playwright called uh named sophocles
and uh he was a very
very hard-working playwright in his life
contemplate this sophocles wrote over
plays i mean shakespeare only wrote what
100 plays that's a lot of plays
and only three or four of those come to
us today what's called extant you know
in in its whole form
but thank goodness
that one of those plays is oedipus rex
oedipus rex in sophocles day
was his big smash hit it was the biggest
hit play in his own lifetime
that he had
and they loved it and they put on other
productions of it going forward kind of
stuff and he was honored for it in many
ways
and that tells us something and here's
my point in starting here
the audiences that responded to oedipus
rex so strongly and so emotionally for
its own culture and time
are exactly the same people with the
same thought processes and the same
functions of processing story
as today
human beings the body of the mind we
haven't changed in 2 500 years we
haven't really i mean you want to go
back 200 000 that's a different story
okay
but no
things that worked the structure that
worked and i've studied
oedipus rex obviously for that to to
nail down the structure it is all there
it is all there
in relative to what we're going to be
seeing here tonight
um
so a lot of people think or newcomers
anyway think
excuse me that structure is somehow
superimposed
and uh it's not it's not it speaks to
how the human mind
processes story
we arrive on this planet craving meaning
that's how our brains our brains are
physical things computers and they
search and well genetically they have
been trained to search for meaning in
all things
150 000 years ago uh you know the vague
scent
on on a
slight breeze or or the echo of an echo
on the other side of a canyon or
something
knowing instantly what these things
meant could be the difference between
life and death so
through the millennia it get it got
baked into the human brain we all seek
meaning and that's what stories give us
life is chaotic life is ambiguous
but we all love the ritual of story
turning
that into meaning
and that's what structure does
yeah the point being obviously
structure is your friend
it is not to be dismissed
as dangerous to your creativity or
something like that if you feel that way
fine because i've worked with a lot of
grad students who feel exactly that way
and it's up to me to convince you
otherwise
i know that's part of my task and i take
it on you know willingly and we will
have those discussions and and arm
wrestlings if you like that's fine with
me too
but the bottom line is
structure is your friend and if you want
to write art movies and you can't stand
hollywood films
we don't care and
the point here being that
um
no in the organization of elements and
stuff like that
at sun tzu the art of war
know your enemy
know this stuff and then if you want to
go off and write independent cinema and
all that great great god
with all of our blessings yes we need
filmmakers and writers like that too
but know what it is you are
not doing
it's important to know what you are
leaving out do it intentionally and not
just you know by mistake
okay first let's construct a specific
story organizing the elements and that's
what structure does
all right like i said we're going back
to the basics here okay
there are three things that need to be
established
in your head when you say oh i got a
great idea for a movie or when you
somebody at a cocktail party comes up
bend your ear
it has to have certain elements to
actually be a good idea for a movie it's
not just a place
where it's not just a particular
character you have to have
a hero yes a sympathetic
active hero
sympathy there are there are nine this
is all in the book two there are nine
basic sympathy tools
um that allow you to create a character
any kind of character
uh
even if you like writing about sleazy
people that's fine
do it but they need still even that
those folks need certain qualities that
make them
empathetic at the very least sympathetic
so that we the audience very quickly and
at the beginning of act one in the
beginning of your movie can identify
with this hero
we have to become emotionally involved
and that's the window that's the window
that you have to let your
audience in on and a hero must be
physically active
they must be we're
that's the kicker here
at the end but uh we'll get there how
the conscious way that you can build and
keep a hero
active throughout two hours
two hours of visual storytelling that's
a lot
and there's a lot that needs to be going
on in there
okay and a little aside
hero the word hero i use the word hero
in the original greek sense
uh i don't know if
you guys know where that came from hero
was the name in greek mythology hero was
the name
of a high priestess of aphrodite
actually hero was originally the name of
a woman
and
hiro had a lover by the name of what was
it leander
and every night you know the high
priestesses lived on this island and
every night then there was this little
channel of ocean between and every night
leander would swim across the channel so
he could spend the night with hero
one night when he was swimming across
the big storm hit and he started to
flail and drown
heroes saw this so the myth goes and she
jumped in and swam out in an attempt to
save him unfortunately in this myth they
both drowned
it was very romeo and juliet i guess
but the point
is it is not gender specific in its
origins it got twisted later on perhaps
but
i'll please
let me use the one word collectively
it's it's women men and and personified
and animated creatures uh
personified animals
one word hero okay okay the second thing
you gotta have is a
physical visible high-stakes goal
this is the difference between novels
we'll talk about this next week in
another you know approaching it from a
different angle too the difference
between novels and movies visual
storytelling
is about creating
visual
metaphors
for interior emotional states
that's what we write
people can't just stand around feeling
they've
the way emotion and character are
revealed
in in visual storytelling is through
behavior
people make decisions and they take
physical actions in pursuit of the goal
whatever that decision uh leads to
so visual in that sense i'm jumping
ahead a little bit here but in that
sense
plot
and character are the same thing
a plot in film in visual storytelling
only exists so that a hero and other
people can behave in a certain way
pursuing something visual that allows us
inside and allows us to know what
emotionally is going on inside of them
there's no narrator you know like in a
novel telling us what's going on inside
of them we have to see it
okay
all of these and the reason these three
are key of course
oh
and then a powerful adversary sorry
powerful adversary and i say powerful
adversary you adversary is the character
who is most
committed to stopping the hero from
getting what they want whatever the goal
is or whatever the genre is as uh and so
forth
and it is the adversary that creates
conflict
you know the hero can't just say i think
i want that chair i'll walk over there
and get that chair no you haven't got a
story until there's a big brutish
somebody or something an obstacle
keeping the hero
from the chair they want
and that
and the conflict must be as high as you
can jack it up under any circumstances
okay
that was kind of a quick very quick
sketch of hero and adversary they
for any story you must have a hero and
you must have an adversary that is
because that is what creates conflict
right
uh that is at its most basic but there
are you're going to trust me for a while
on this there are 14 character
categories that work in visual
storytelling only 14
and that's not a bad thing actually it
simplifies your plot planning to know
and know these categories well because
each of these categories prov
provide characters that must serve the
function
of either hindering or helping the hero
in the pursuit of their goal
if you have a character that doesn't do
either
they are not meaningful to the story and
unless they're just atmosphere people
which are props in essence
get rid of them they can't just hang out
there
although
these categories get rather broad and
i'm going to get highly specific next
time we meet on the character categories
you really need to get your head around
how to use these because one of the
things i see coming in uh through the
students and the first years and stuff
when they start writing and creating
their own plots is
a paucity
of subplot
it is the character category list
that gives you on a silver platter
subplots
and subplots can take so much pressure
over off of your plotting when it's just
a hero and just the adversary on and on
and on and on you have to keep changing
the nature of the conflict
and these other characters are going to
help just for now i threw it in here so
if you take a look okay that's them
those are the categories you don't have
to rush and jot all these down i'll have
handouts not tonight but i'll have
handouts it's in the book also it's all
in the book but just kind of an overview
of what it will take to build a plot
that works for audiences and stays
focused
there are the categories
all right
now
you have your idea and now we begin to
build
a screen story structure
two hours worth and and that's biting
off a lot let's see
first of all you have to have an idea
as discussed three key elements all of
them must be in there to make your idea
viable for conflict
going forward with a story the second
thing you have to come up with
is an ending
a lot of people
novices
specifically they say leave me alone i'm
just going to take these people and i'm
going to run with it i'm going to start
writing and making scenes and they'll
tell me where they want to go and
usually not always but usually those
scripts
end i mean are
are abandoned about page 48
and dropped in a drawer because they get
lost i mean the writer gets lost in the
weeds and that's another reason why
getting organized is so darned important
there are tools here
it's like you know lumber and electrical
cable that you're being offered the
tools for building a house
it's kind of hard to just dismiss them
out of hand i would think
the ending
to la in large measure screenplays are
written from the back forward
or at least they're constructed from the
back forward
where do you want it to end you got an
idea for a character and a conflict
what is the emotion you want to go for
what is the feeling of that final
climatic scene and where is it going to
take place that is important for you to
think through and pick something and
write it down in your outline as you
build your outline here
that's for now the ending and listen all
of these things
you're not tied to them obviously if you
get into this and you say you suddenly
find something that's a better idea for
you and you want to go in that direction
fine rewrite your outline
all i'm saying is you need the basics
lined up so that you're going somewhere
and you because that's that's
if you don't know the ending or and
possible ending that you are going for
you are inviting writer's block you
really are and that's how people get
lost in swamps out there and until they
just you know they can't
face the headache and they
and they put it away
okay the ending stunning surprise one
stunning surprise too i'm going to spend
a little time this evening with examples
of stunning surprise one and stunning
surprise two
now these
this is my my name my my uh
title for these key
moments you probably know them as they
they happen at the end of act one and at
the end of act two they are the biggest
reversals in your entire story and you
need to know where you're going for them
up front you need to know
soon plan it because sometimes you have
to work on them to really get them juicy
and big
i use the words what is it
uh uh sid field i think said uh it was
the first
plot points one and two that's it that's
what he called it
and even joseph campbell said it was
crossing the first threshold was you
know stunning surprise one all of which
is true and all of which is great
but i think those are
abstract terms and i prefer terms that
are not abstract even if they're a bit
over the top like stunning surprise
because that should be the impact of
that moment that you are creating for
your audience
really impactful it should be emotional
visible
and very impactful
on the hero
okay
we're going to get to that just right
away here and of this first order of
business
and in what you're lining up you also
need to decide early on you know before
you start
writing script pages wait on script
pages
because once you write script pages it
gets harder and harder to throw them
away but we'll get on that
you need to know where the beginning
goes
where are you going to start you know
where it ends you know approximately
what some of the big moments will be
who is doing what to whom the nature of
the conflict now where do you start
because you can still blow it there too
you know
if you start too soon
you know if you start too late
even by a couple of scenes you push it
because you want to get it moving and
rolling
you haven't given your audience enough
time to connect emotionally with your
hero
that's really important that stuff that
happens up front and unless it's an
action movie you know it was a james
bond or something like that which always
starts his ordinary world yeah is
running and chasing and shooting i mean
that's what he does so okay that's his
ordinary world
and you begin there but you have to give
your audience a few moments
some scenes for them to connect
emotionally
with your hero
before you can really get rolling and
have them come along for the ride and
i've seen a number of uh european films
british films for some reason
specifically
not all of them
but i've seen them start way too early
and they can go on for 20 minutes or so
there was one uh called the layer cake
was that
it's a great gangster movie
but i don't know if you're as i remember
the beginning it just is it lays there i
mean they're just talking and hanging
out and it goes on and on and on and
you're waiting for the movie to start
no picking your your beginning i mean
yes your
your beginning is really important after
that
you got three acts and you i think it's
helpful to view your three acts or think
of them as
three worlds
and that's why i broke it down this way
by by way of example
act one traditionally is called
the ordinary world
or the hero's life yesterday
what the hero's life has been like
up to
very close to but not past just before
this kicks in
what you're doing
the ordinary world in act one
after the inciting incident
the hero will have a general goal a
general goal in act one
of an ordinary world
for instance
i'm going to use shrek here in just a
second as an example
but the ordinary world of shrek how many
of you have
not seen shrek
okay
i i figured that would be the case
when i mention these and i use them as
examples please jot down the titles of
these movies
you really it is well worth your time
and effort to get these films and make
time to spend time with them
and view them
they i pick them because they're really
good examples of one thing or another
but shrek is an ogre who lives in a
swamp
and uh he's happy he thinks
before character growth
but then lord farquaad drives all these
fairy tale creatures into his swamp and
all of a sudden he just is going nuts
he's got to get rid of these fairytale
creatures because he wants to be left
alone in his swamp
that is his general goal of act one then
he marches off to do lock right to find
lord farquaad and demand he gets rid of
them this is all act one stuff it is the
hero pursuing a general goal and then
something happens at the end of act one
to drop the curtain on that and raise
the curtain immediately on act two where
now the goal has become
highly specific
that's with them highly specific and
it's it's often called the special world
act ii
because it is a world
that the hero has never experienced
before by the nature of the
circumstances sometimes it's a physical
difference
but
a lot of the times it's just i mean like
if it's a real-life contemporary thing
you know it's still in manhattan
but what the hero is now facing
makes it
incredibly different and special
and life or deathish
in act two and then act two
the hero uh
forms a plan
and pursues the plan throughout act two
cobbling it together as it gets keeps
getting torn apart and then as at the
climax of act two as you roll into
stunning surprise two
the plan gets totally blown out of the
water and destroyed and all of a sudden
there is no plan it's the biggest
reversal in the entire movie
and then that throws the hero into act
three where they must improvise there is
no longer any plan but the best i think
really useful way to see your three acts
is this is
adolescence this is your hero's
adolescence i don't care how old they
are physically but this is emotional
adolescence
and then you get into the special world
where they realize they darn well better
grow up or they're never going to be
emotionally
or they're never going to be able to do
what they need to do to get to their
goal
and then act three is
their maturity now they're an adult
now they get it now they have overcome
some of the
emotional uh
reticence within
and they are ready to face
the adversary for all the marbles
i break one down here as as an example
okay this is collateral
i don't mean to
nail people but how many of you have not
seen collateral
oh okay good it's okay uh write it down
okay
um this is a thriller
actually a
relatively big budget
american
thriller that was a hit all over he got
some academy awards too i do believe
um
yeah there's a lot to study there in
fact we may we may be looking at it
ourselves later on in the class
okay the hero this is a one hero movie
and the hero is max
max the cab driver ordinary max
but in act one his ordinary world he has
been planning and dreaming of starting
his own
limo company for 12 years
which
you know
he doesn't get the fact that that's
ridiculous that he should have launched
it years ago
but he's afraid to take that risk the
plan's got to be perfect so basically
the underlying problem emotionally that
max has is he has no courage
then stunning surprise one happens and
all of a sudden boom
uh rear end over tea kettle he flies
into act two
and he's been kidnapped by a hitman
being forced to drive him around for the
rest of the night as he kills people
and all of a sudden the lack of courage
thing
becomes
the
the monstrosity stumbling block between
max
and being alive by tomorrow morning
if he doesn't get the guts to do
something to confront this killer and
take the risks
comitant and all that he's not going to
live the night so now there are reasons
where he's better start growing up fast
and he does and it's really great by the
time he gets to act three
believably the ark is so beautiful the
character growth arc and believably in
act 3 max becomes a genuine hero
you know not a superhero
but he's fighting the bad guy because
he's trying to save
the woman you'll see you'll see
but that's uh uh another way of looking
at it
and as an example of basic structure of
that particular film okay
inciting incident these are the dramatic
tent poles
acts one two three and that the whole
point is they need to keep rising you
know they have to
or you're gonna lose your audience they
can't just float along
two main things happen in act one the
inciting incident and stunning surprise
one which ends the act
uh there's some of these things i'm not
going to go into tonight but the
inciting incident a lot of people mix up
the inciting incident with stunning
surprise one and
we'll talk about that going forward and
we'll see a lot of examples
but uh
for instance
the inciting incident for e.t the s the
extraterrestrial most of you i'm sure
have seen e.t that's i'd like to take my
examples from a few years ago assuming
that most of you have seen these things
what is the inciting incident of e.t the
extraterrestrial
any thoughts
yes
yeah yes uh yes it comes to that but
first
yes
well we're not in the shed but close
real close um
yeah the thing is a lot of people have
said that well it's it's it's when e.t
is left behind and a spaceship takes off
that launches this story the definition
for the inciting incident is
it begins this story and no other
well
it's not that's not the moment because
number one e.t is not the hero as you
know many of you have already
nailed e.t is not the hero e.t is what's
called the endangered innocent
eliot the boy is the hero and the
inciting incident that starts all of
this
is when the the thing in the shed and
all this and he goes off looking for
something strange in in the high grass
and the weeds and they open the weeds
and they see each other face to face for
the first time inches apart and they're
both terrified and scream and turn and
run around and run away
that's the inciting incident for e.t
because then
from that point on elliot is obsessed
with finding that wonderful strange
looking puppy dog and making him making
that his pet and there's the soul in
terms of the the character growth arc he
keeps talking about e.t as as if he was
a puppy dog
and then
stunning surprise one
all of a sudden
when he asks ct where do you come from
and all the globs of play-doh rise and
with power of mind he is showing him
things in the air and you know pointing
at different planets and stuff like that
and at that moment and that's why i
think what he says what eliot says is of
all the things he could possibly say he
says
oh no
in other words what he had was all wrong
his assumption about e.t
this is not a dog
this is
the smartest most advanced
incredibly powerful creature currently
on the face of the earth
that's what he's got himself into and
that takes
elliott kicks him you know rear end over
t kettle into the second act where the
focused goal becomes
get that creature home
save his life and get him home so
there's one example okay
that's the the nature of the inciting
incident
studying surprise well let's see what's
next
yeah okay
stunning surprise the these are the
basic factors of the stunning surprise
but usually usually there's wiggle room
here folks but usually 25 to 35 minutes
it usually depends on how long the movie
is if the movie is 2 hours 20 minutes
you know it can be 44 minutes into the
movie it depends
25 to 35 minutes into the movie it must
happen to the hero
and it takes place in an instant it's
one of those it's not a scene that
develops and reveals it takes place in
an instant it shocks and surprises the
hero and us and the audience
and it presents what the storyline is
going to be about
just like
elliott
when he gets you know kicked into the
second act it very quickly becomes
apparent that he knows and we know the
storyline is going to be about saving
e.t
all right
okay this is from this is from get out
that this
amazing film an amazing launch of
careers here it really was
but that is a kind of
the moment
of stunning surprise
it is frequently eyes large mouth open
it is a true shock
it has to be a shock to the hero going
in
okay here's an example
so shrek has gone off
he's really ticked off about the fairy
tale creatures and he storms off to go
find lord farquaad he goes to duloc
nobody's in the town and then he hears
people cheering in the arena inside the
palace so he heads in there to find
why is this
hmm
there's some sort of contest about to
take place
and uh and he sees lord farquaad up on
top of his draperies or whatever
and uh shrek being shrek he's not afraid
of anything or anyone he just goes
barging on in there to take his uh
complaint to lord farquaad get rid of
the fairy tale creatures
but remember as soon as lord farquaad
sees him
he says oh
that gruesome ogre how horrible how ugly
new plan the knight who kills the ogre
will be champion
of course
shrek is completely unfazed says oh
can't we discuss this over a pint
whatever it was and so all the knights
come after shrek and shrek turns it into
a very comical sequence very nice and a
perfect
climactic action sequence
to end an act acts rises even act one
you rise to a climax and then act two
rises to a bigger climax there has to be
a climax to the act
and the audience is is having a great
time they're cheering him on and then a
little lady said give him a chair the
references references to professional
wrestling and all that kind of stuff one
by one and three by three he dispenses
knocks out
all the guards and
then the people are cheering
and shrek is having a great time and
eating up eating it up and so is donkey
donkey's proud too
but then suddenly a reversal
a bunch of crossbows get cocked and
pointed at them
uh that changes the situation oops
and then the captain of the guard says
to lord farquaad you know shall i give
the order sir
hmm
being the and the consummate politician
that all schmucky
authoritarians are
he says wait i got a better plan
and he gives the audience what they want
people of the lock i give you your
champion
what
uh say what
there's the look
it is the reversal
eyes
mouth
the classic
stunning surprise one look
and what is that done
now
shrek's general goal of get rid of the
fairytale creatures has just become the
very next scene and he and very quickly
uh uh he's told by
farquaad that if you go to the dragon's
keep and you bring the princess to me
i will give you your swamp back
boom
now his desire to get rid of the fairy
tale creatures in general
has become a specific thing
go to the dragon the dragon's keep save
the princess and bring her back to
farquaad highly specific what he now has
to do
that is the function of a stunning
surprise one
and
all of these apply to uh shrek 25 35
minutes into the movie i believe it
happens at 26 minutes must happen to the
hero always always must and it does
takes place in an instant i give you
your champion huh
yes it takes place in an instant shocks
and surprises the hero heavens heavens
yes and presents what the storyline will
be
this stunning surprise one
does all of it fulfills all of the
requirements okay
here's another one just one more
four stunning surprise one
okay cab driver max is a sweet guy
and very sympathetic on on a number of
levels
uh and he's uh
i don't know he's
the one of the most time accurate
cab drivers anybody has ever met his cab
is immaculately cleaned this is
something else about your hero
whatever they do
you know a nuclear physicist to a cab
driver
make them
tops at it
they have to be highly skilled in what
it is they do
now i don't care what it is that they do
yeah and on all levels it's a subtle
thing but it's really important they
can't just be a screw-up schlub
you're not going to hold an audience
that way
okay
so uh uh
another guy has gotten into his cab he
doesn't know yet that vincent
is a killer
but uh he's just dropping him off took
him affair and he's dropping him off but
then vincent comes up with his 600 offer
and i said you stick with me for the
rest of the night drive me around i got
a few more places to go and then get me
to the airport in time in the morning
right
and
max kind of hams and haws it's against
regulations
but
he says okay it's it's for him one shift
tonight you know 600 bucks is pretty
good plus a bonus when he gets in there
so he takes the deal in this movie that
is the inciting incident
when max unknowingly though but in
retrospect we will see
when he takes the deal that binds him
to vincent
and
that leads to stunning surprise stunning
surprise too very quickly i'm one very
quickly
he says go around and wait for me in the
alley and like a good hero he doesn't
waste any time the hero should always be
doing something so he uses the wait time
to eat his lunch and
look at
i need to turn this bit
and look at his catalogs
for the cars he's going to take on lease
for his limo service he's been doing
this for 12 years
he hasn't launched it yet
but as he is deep into his reverie
out of nowhere
kaboom
something big and squishy hits the top
of his cab and it happens to
be keep pointing it at the screen
instead of the computer
it happens to be a human being who is
squished
well
the effect that has
on max is uh quite strong and he
immediately goes into shock and he's
he's terrified and he fumbles and
stumbles and gets out of the car falls
onto the ground crawls away
trying to make sense of it
this is not
stunning surprise one
it is not stunning surprise one yet
the reason is this
stunning surprise one has to change
everything
change the hero's life
forever
going back to shrek he's going off to
fetch a princess he thinks just you know
to get rid of the fairy tale creatures
that journey will change his life
forever ultimately he's going to fall in
love for the first time in his life and
that will change everything all right
here
he's a cab driver and that's pretty
outrageous to have dead body fall on top
of your cab and it's kind of scary
but realistically it is not outside of
what normally happens in a city he could
you know go have a great tale uh maybe
it'll be written up in the newspapers
and tomorrow night he'll be driving a
new cab
his old life would continue
yeah it's spooky and it's big and it's
dramatic and loud but it does not yet
change his life
so
vincent comes mumbling out
very self-controlled
and
max is all rattled and he said trying to
put the guy failed look i fell it fell
right in my cab
i think he's dead
uh
good guess
vincent plays at low key
and at that moment the thought finally
crosses max's mind
you killed him
i think vincent says you know i shot him
it was the bullet in the fall that
killed him
i mean it's the kind of cynical snide
guy he is for a killer right
and even this is not the stunning
surprise yet because he has to
get that linked up with one more factor
before it changes his life forever and
it's this
uh
vincent's try to stop him from running
away point pulls the gun points a gun at
him
and now he gets it
this is stunning surprise one and look
at the expression
it is the stunning surprise expression
because now he knows the full story
which is he is
the captive
of an assassin
and that mean and he knows i mean he's
seen his face he's had conversations
with the guy assassins don't let such
people live
so
he now sees that this is called you know
passover tea kettle here in into act two
because now for the first time he is in
the special world of being a hostage of
a man who kills people for a living that
he has to drive around for the rest of
the night and the possibilities of max
coming out the other side of this you
know by morning getting away from this
guy are practically new practically
impossible
so now max has faced a situation he's
never faced before and that is called a
special world indeed
how is he going to pull this off
mild-mannered max is going to confront
this guy with life and death
act two begins
uh and the difference here is uh where
is it there it is 25 35 minutes
in in collateral i think act 1 is 19
minutes 19 minutes long
i'm pretty sure pretty short for act one
yes
but think about why
this story is about a cab driver act one
his ordinary world
almost all takes place inside of a cab
this is a thriller the movie is a
thriller
you've got to get
something going you've got to get the
story pumped up and running
quickly
not in 25 minutes no
people aren't going to hang around
you've got to do it as soon as possible
a lot of stuff is set up in act 1 and in
that 19 minutes and we're going to take
a close look at this coming up in a few
weeks
oh the brilliance with which this thing
was composed this first act
but that's why it has to be shorter and
that is another statement
of the paradigm being flexible in some
ways
okay that was stunning surprise one
then there's midpoint uh we're not going
into the midpoint tonight the midpoint
is juicy and there's a great deal to be
discussed about the midpoint the
midpoint is not
a moment like a stunning surprise it's
not just one moment of shock
it is uh it's a series as not always but
as a rule it's a series of short
scenes in which several key things that
advance the story happen including and
one of them is is it's a key character
growth moment
and we'll talk about that another time
but now i want to jump to the other key
one most important one which is stunning
surprise too
some of the same things and some new
things in stunning surprise too this
this is the climax and and the curtain
dropper
for the end of act two and a lot goes i
mean the bulkier movie i mean since act
two can be 70 pages even more of of your
screenplay
and that's why it deserves a lot of
attention and a lot of thought and
planning and we'll get to that
it is the biggest reversal in the whole
movie this is the biggest dramatic event
in your whole movie takes place in an
instant yes shocks and surprises yes
but here the hero's plan is destroyed
um that means at the beginning of act
two
um
the hero kind of picks themselves up
dusts themselves off and now they have a
very highly specific and difficult task
ahead of them a goal so they start
formulating a plan
and sometimes they start gathering
allies
as uh campbell says sorting out enemies
and allies in that first section of act
two and getting their feet on the ground
forming a plan
and moving forward with it and at toward
the end of act two
you know as as the action is rising
toward the end of the act and the climax
it just just might be possible for the
hero to pull this off it's looking more
and more like it's feasible
and then boom stunning surprise two hits
and the plan is totally obliterated the
plan no longer exists
and it is called the hero's darkest hour
now it looks like the hero
is finished
and let me remind this
it sounds a lot sometimes like i'm only
talking about action movies
that's not the case
this invariable degrees is all genres
family dramas this is what they are too
it's just that these things these
contests these conflicts become between
two people one person trying to dominate
another or convince them of something
all of this is true for all genres
that work
that work for audiences okay
uh
and it because it's often called the
hero's darkest hour
uh
but i throw this in because i've got an
example coming up again to show you a
variation about five or ten percent
of all the movies that work
have a reversal to the positive
in other words by the end of act two the
hero is kind of
down
and then it has to be the biggest
reversal you can't go super down you're
if you're already kind of down and it
goes up
and the big difference is when you do
that and that's fine
i mean there's a lot of romantic
comedies and and others and dramas and
other things like that
uh bridesmaids is like that
erin brockovich is like that
but what that means is
act three has to be very short
because
the hero is already one
see so the obligatory scene the day new
mall
you get on with those and you wrap it up
and you're you're out your story is over
uh okay let's uh take a look at an
example
ah
not yet this is stunning surprise two
of the matrix
okay this is a more traditional stunning
surprise okay
uh
how many have not seen the matrix
okay
write it down
alrighty good make a note
this this was this was a genre-changing
movie i mean we've seen all kinds of
movies like it now and you know the
twists and the concepts that were used
in the matrix but when the matrix came
along
it had impact it was fresh these story
ideas
the concepts and the way they were
executed
they
ultimately affected science fiction
forever as a genre
so okay
this is a one hero movie as all of these
are uh and the hero is neo
and uh he just uh saved the life of his
mentor morpheus
and uh and he was helped by by the love
interest character trinity and he got
them to a phone booth and that's how
the technician on
their ship uh the nebuchadnezzar
on the the rebels ship that's how uh
tank gets them
out of the mat the matrix back on on
board the ship and he got morpheus and
trinity back on the ship but then the
bad person shows up the adversary agent
smith shows up and they have a big fight
and it's like a fight to the draw
and uh
neo is making a run for it but he had a
cell phone so he's still talking to tank
and tank is sending him to
another place where he can be extracted
by telephone
okay
they're running the robots
are running after him too
and ah
one of the better adversaries
in film agent smith is also close on his
tail closer than neo actually realizes
their cannons are being shot zinging
and oh yeah this too
this is what i mean about visual
metaphors
we we spend a couple seconds going back
to the nebuchadnezzar which is also been
simultaneously attacked by these robotic
spiders that are just evil looking
through and through and they are
literally tearing uh
the seals off of it the siding off of it
and they are seconds from storming
inside and killing every human being in
the nebuchadnezzar
one of the few groups of human beings
still alive in this world
what this does though
what this does is remind us the audience
visually
that it's not just neo trying to save
his own life
neo is responsible for all of these
people and that's what makes him a hero
a true hero he is doing yes he's in
danger but he's got to get back for the
protection of other people and that the
definition of hero there it is
okay he's running down a grungy hall
remember that those of you have seen it
it's an interesting climax this visually
quite striking too
he's running he's running he's being
chased and he hears a phone ringing
behind the door i guess it's just where
tank told him it it would be and he'd
better get there fast and he goes up to
the door
i wonder why they picked room i mean
303 usually when a filmmaker puts a
number like that it has significance
maybe it's trinities you know
two trinities i don't know
but the phone is ringing
and he throws the door open
oops
agent swiss smith is waiting for him
with this hand cannon pointed at his
chest it's over there is no escaping for
for neo under this circumstance so but
what wait a minute i'll go back see
he's this his face is smaller but look
at the expression
eyes wide mouth open stunning surprise
one yes neo you're dead
that is pretty stunning surprising
then he braces himself to take it like a
hero
and he shot six seven eight times i
forget it's just
the way they sound the juice to the
sound to make those sound like cannon
shots blasting out of that gun it's very
powerful
and ouch
and then there's another cut back to the
nebuchadnezzar
to remind us
visually we have to be shown physically
and visibly that's how we get our
information in movies
in visual media we are once again
reminded that if you die in the matrix
you die for real
and that's what this little cut is
reminding us
and this is shots it's got sparks going
on in the background there was some you
know as as the uh
the little spidery things are coming
uh it's like the whole place is falling
apart but there's
heavenly sparks also
and kabang
he keeps pumping him in and there he is
the blood smear on the wall
fading going going and oh yeah poor
morpheus
because morpheus is the mentor character
and he had all his bucks
you know he was convinced that that neo
was going to be the one the prophesied
person who would come and save humanity
from the machines right that's a thing
running running through the whole film
it's this
it's very religious you know it's like a
christ metaphor truly the whole film is
and he can't believe it my god how can
he be wrong if if neo is dead
neo hits the floor
dead he's shot so many times he has to
be dead he falls to the floor he looks
pretty dead and then agent smith has one
of his guys check him so he goes up
he's gone
you know he's as dead as they can make
him right we get it he's dead
goodbye mr anderson
okay
biggest reversal in the whole film
you betcha takes place in an instant yes
shocks and surprises of course hero's
plan is destroyed i would say so if
you're dead that kind of does in your
plan
and it's often called the hero's darkest
hour
it is somebody's darkest hour there i
would say so
so
and it was very shocking in the theaters
i don't know if you guys know the first
time i saw it what
how can they just kill off the hero you
know
but they did and then did something very
interesting from there
but that is stunning surprise too
here is my second hang on hang on i know
it's tough just give me a little longer
i got with this one more example and
then i'm going to show you some
stuff you're not going to hear anywhere
else
so how crazy is that okay
uh a second example in a completely
different kind of movie in uh uh erin
brockovich right she's been told she and
ed the the mentor character the her
attorney have been told they need 164 or
167 more signatures they're going to
have it decided by a judge rather than a
jury which takes
years they said okay now they're going
to arbitrate with a judge so they find
she's finally got all the signatures she
needs
but what she doesn't have
is
smoking gun
the absolute
proof
that pg e you know pacific gas and
electric because it was based on a real
story that pacific gas and electric knew
that they were poisoning the residents
of hinckley
that is what the smoking gun is in this
particular story and nobody's come
anywhere near that
she goes she gets signatures
no smoking gun
so end of a very long day but she's
gotten her signatures so she goes to a
local bar and coffee you know coffee
shop please
but she's still deeply worried about not
having any smoking gun
and then down the bar there's mr sleeves
remember
charles embry i think was the
character's name
he's been kind of stalking her for a
little while since the midpoint just
this kind of sleazy guy in the
background is looking funny and eyeing
her funny and
he uh starts to chatter up the guy tries
to start a conversation this is not a
good time place or circumstance for
aaron she needs like this like a hole in
the head
and then he moves in a little closer
oozes down a couple of chairs
right
he slides closer tries more compliments
says things like
i think you're the kind of person i
could talk to
uh you know the intention it's double
entendre of course you know but it's
nice how they play up to one thing and
then reverse it as they are about to
and of course she's
trying to cool him down
show his little interest reverse
interest the lack of it but he doesn't
let up so she grabs her stuff
and she's taken off and when she's
actually leaving
she's not going to be there to talk with
him anymore suddenly
charles embry bursts out with
would it be important to you if i told
you when i worked at the hinckley plant
i destroyed documents
what
bingo sounds like a smoking gun to her
right
and next watch what happens next though
that is stunning surprise too but watch
how it is played out
she she's she's getting rattled with
charles says uh uh can you wait with me
just wait here wait here i i gotta go to
the bathroom i'll be right back i
promise you know and she goes running
out of the bar and she goes tries to get
her phone and of course the phone
doesn't have any power and she tries to
get change out of her purse and her
purse drops and the coins fly and
finally she's so nervous and so excited
what happened
powerpoint crashed oh yes okay
um and uh she gets ed on the phone the
attorney you know and she gets him all
excited too oh well just
don't push him don't let him talk you
know people like to tell her and both of
them very very excited and then she goes
back in for a calm conversation with
charles embry but the thing is this
these extra moments
susanna grant wrote the screenplay here
of of aaron brockovich and it is bloody
brilliant she does a number of things
little things like this
this is a stunning surprise but it is
very quiet it is exactly what the hero
needs but it's kind of downplayed and
quiet so all of a sudden uh
we take her excitement as the hero and
she runs off and shares her excitement
with the mentor
and the moment is built
to show us
the the depth and breadth of what it
means to what they are doing this is it
we have won
and it's added you know to give us a
sense of that rising excitement
and very wisely very very wisely so
now
back to this problem the unexpected has
struck
wait a minute why has it come back
sorry
just give me a couple of seconds here
because i got
finally get to the juicy stuff
wouldn't you know
stunning surprise too
the plan is blown apart
it's the hero's darkest hour
as soon as i get this back up again i
got to take you through this stuff
you have been so patient
and you've hung in so well uh and yes
all of this is going to a destination
and it's an important destination and i
hope you'll be intrigued by it
we shall see
ah
getting warmer
the wheel of death i don't know
okay well did you stretch yes
not much of a stretch nah
we don't let let you get away with much
around here
um okay this is the summary of of type b
okay
biggest reversal yes takes place in an
instant shocks and surprises but here
the hero's victory
is delivered
you win
there's still an obligatory scene to
come and ex
a highly unusual and extraordinarily
emotionally fulfilling one too when she
goes back to the office and
she lays into the in in a comical way
lays into the two stuffed shirt
attorneys they've gone into business
with and all kind of stuff
uh so she gets another victory she gets
a social like victory that is on top of
this one but this is the fact act three
better be short when this happens you
get
a short two more hero goal sequences and
we'll talk about that right now
all right
take a breath
there are two things that drive
all screenplays that work all of them
visual stories two
one is conflict
you got to have lots and lots and lots
of it and if you have weak conflict
or not very interesting conflict you
you're going to lose your audience but
the second one is a bit of an
abstraction that haunted me for years
which is
you also have to have change
the story flow
absolutely needs to be changing as you
go forward it has to be developing going
forward
and i found it impossible to to teach
that you know that wasn't either it's
one of those things you use there's an
instinct you have or you don't have kind
of thing but it infuriated me i've
always felt that there was something
there that could be teachable
so that's when i went into the weeds and
the jungles for a few years and started
watching
movies over and over and over and over
trying to find
a pattern in change that had not yet
been codified i know that's a pretty
outrageous thing to say and to be
looking for
and i was shocked more than anyone when
i actually realized i was looking at one
there is a pattern to change in these
films
in the way they speak to the human mind
and emotions and process
this information of story to make it
emotionally fulfilling
there is a unit of change
that you can get your hands on
and it seemed to me if you could truly
codify
the length and content
of one unit of change you might really
have something
in terms of
the most useful tool for outlining a
feature film i've i've ever seen
anywhere else and i try to stay on top
of these things
define the size and content of the units
of change in successful screen stories
and you can build a more effective way
to write screenplays and this is a fact
and the unit of change
that i found i named hero gold sequences
again
because it that refers to actions rather
than abstractions
here are the definitions
i'm going to read these i don't want to
you know muff it
so i'm going to read
it a hero goal sequence we're talking
about a unit of change a hero goal
sequence consists of three to seven
pages of screen play there's wiggle room
there i've seen him at two pages i've
seen them at nine pages
generally three to seven pages of
screenplay wherein a hero pursues
one
short term
physical goal
as one step
toward achieving
the overarching goal of the whole story
then the hero discovers in pursuit of
that one short-term goal
some form of what i call fresh news
some sort of information or object that
they happen into that is one of the
you've got to have so many surprises for
an audience in a feature film it is one
of the small surprises
and you say hmm that's interesting
and that fresh news puts an end to the
current short-term goal
and offers up
the next
short term goal
and the next hero goal sequence
begins
this is a schematic of it
i mean i started it one i you know okay
so you come here
you've got a goal you're searching for
the goal and then boom
fresh news it is a mini mini mini
stunning surprise
you know mini
it's not the big thing and all of a
sudden this goal comes to an end it's
not needed anymore or it's completed or
whatever then boom you're up to the next
level of involvement and interest and
growing tension in the story
here's an example concrete time
gravity how many of you have not seen
gravity
okay
i think we're i've decided i think we're
going to look at gravity in here because
there's so much to be learned from that
film
um
but here is where it starts
hero goal one in gravity is the ordinary
world of the hero
the hero of that movie is sandra bullock
who plays dr ryan stone
who is in space
working on space station
because of a deep deep wound that she
received when her four-year-old daughter
fell off of a jungle gym and died
she lost her daughter and her meaning of
life
in a freak accident
and she is so profoundly in grief what
she has done is
gone as far away from life
and the earth as she can possibly get
into total silence the depth of silence
of space so she is up there and she's
doing her work and her goal is to work
in space without thinking or feeling
fresh news and that that sequence also
establishes other members of the crew
and it establishes her uh her mentor
character the george clooney character
kowalski i think was his name and fresh
news after x number of minutes is
houston suddenly calls and says abort
mission return immediately a wide swath
of space junk is heading right at you
and now they're scrambling and trying to
get inside with the other astronauts
there i think there's three of them out
there working at the time
and she's caught up in what she's doing
she's trying to finish and reboot you
know she's being focused on that and and
kowalski keeps saying get inside
now and you can't move too fast in space
suits and all that
and fresh news so get inside the space
space craft and return right away and
fresh news become
becomes they don't make it
the debris storm hits
and they're right in its path
then that becomes
a hero goal sequence three which is
do everything you can to survive the
debris storm
you see those are actions that pile up
on each other
this is just one taste i mean this is
i'm gonna have your head spinning with
perhaps you think too much of this stuff
going forward in the course
but this is the ticket guys this is a
secret
and here's the weird part
this is what i wanted to get to finally
thank you for hanging in
through technical disaster and all
okay
this is what act one looks like
act one listen you know hear this this
i'm still astounded but this is true
act one in any motion picture
that works for audiences
and was a big hit
act one of all of them no matter their
genre
have six hero goal sequences in it
six
not five
not seven
six
and stunning surprise one
always
appears in hero goal six always
it never fails if the movie doesn't work
then that's not the case
i mean i mean
i i invite you to and i've done a lot of
it too you
you've got to watch bad movies too
but from now on when you see bad movies
i don't want to hear just ah i didn't
like it it stinks
you got to tell me why it stinks
where did they fail in in their mission
to bring you emotion
how did they blow it i want you to be
able to spot and you will soon enough be
able to spot exactly why it didn't work
okay
and the weirdness continues
here's the graph of act two act two is
broken in half by the midpoint sequence
the first half of act two
contains
another six hero goal sequences
and the midpoint sequence and every good
movie has a really good midpoint
sequence and that's saying something
because these aren't easy at all
and the midpoint sequence always appears
in hero goal sequence number 12
always
and in the second half
second half of act two
is another guess what another six hero
goal sequences
and stunning surprise too
always appears in hero goal sequence 18
not in 19 not in 17 or 16 in 18
in every movie
that works emotionally for
audiences uh act three is the only place
it can vary
act three contains between two and five
hero goal sequences
there's a minimum of two because
remember there is the obligatory scene
and the denouement two things are
critical and they have to happen in act
three
and they each need their own goal
sequence so that's why the minimum is
two
and the maximum is five
but hear me please there are
a few really good movies i mean my
favorite romantic comedy of all time as
good as it gets it has five but it has
to wrap up so much and there are so many
important relationships that have to be
wrapped up in act three okay we cut it
some slack i am asking you
short of begging
do not
go with five hero goal sequences
in your act three
it makes the act too long and your
audience gets restless it did the
stories or movies we go to and we feel
that they have rep it keeps ending over
and over and it's still ending kind of
thing that is the feeling you're in
danger of creating
keep act three short that is what it's
meant to be
the average
for a successful hollywood movie that is
loved all over the world the average is
21 in other words three hero goal
sequences in act three
here's here's a graph of the entire
thing
and here is your challenge
this i believe is
extraordinarily good news for you
you now know
in advance
exactly how much story your screenplay
is going to need
if it is to be a hit with audiences if
it is to affect them and connect with
them emotionally
this is what it needs to be and i'm
believe me i'm setting out to prove it
to you and i will prove it to you this
semester
in spades that it's true and it's true
across all genres because this is about
you know
this takes us back to greece this is
about speaking to how your audience
absorbs sto the ritual
of story
that's what it's speaking to
but here's the problem with it i mean
this is
really
i think enormously useful and valuable
knowledge but take a look at the number
of little surprises you have to come up
with
i've had grad students you know working
on you know some of the actual writing
courses and
working on stuff
and uh
oh eric eric i only got four sequences
in the second half of act two that's all
i can think of that's all i got can't i
just have four in in the second half of
act two
and the old task master shakes his head
no i'm sorry
if you can only come up with four that
means you have to go back in your story
to find why that is true it's telling
you that your earlier story has not been
built in such a way that this can be
provided as you go forward
you have to go back to your basics that
kind of thing so in other words this is
your challenge this is an incredible
challenge to wrestle with
so grit your teeth because
that's the facts guys
and here's what it is accomplished by
knowing this
which i think is enormously useful
it shows you in advance exactly how much
plot you need
exactly how many times you know
sequences of change you're going to have
to arrange and invent
one of the things about it's in the book
and we'll talk about this stuff too
later but for instance
another thing about the hero goal
sequences you cannot repeat
you cannot have two hero goal sequences
that are basically the same
if you have one that is sort of the same
of something that has preceded
you then have to add to it something
major
that changes it and makes it unique
before you can use it
it shows you exactly how much plot you
need and sometimes this is cold chills
at night because it's a lot of plot it
ensures that the hero will always be
active
one of the two or three
most deadly things that kill
so many scripts from neophytes is a
passive hero
think uh the kind of story that things
happen to the hero and the hero doesn't
happen to the story driving the story
forward on their own it doesn't work
like that if you do this
the hero is always active
21 times they are in pursuit of a
physical goal they can never be passing
and what's interesting is that's what
happens in movies that connect with
audiences
the heroes are not passive ever they're
doing something that moves the story
forward the story will never sag that's
built in
and what we know is that
this is the best you are building
something for the best possible
emotional involvement of your audience
this we're talking psychology here
really that's truly what it is
this is kind of a finger on a certain
kind of absorption of a of a ritual
this is what brings emotion and pleasure
to an audience and that's that's what
you have to wrestle with
um
oh yeah
and this is good too a lot of people
talk about this
a lot of the grad students go back to
their closets
and pull out old stuff you know you got
a half a script here and there you gave
up in
[Music]
in high school or something like that
you thought you were you were going to
go somewhere and uh or you pull out old
scripts you finished a draft maybe a
couple of three drafts but it just never
quite worked they never sailed you know
a couple people read it and you know
they weren't into put it away
take it out take this paradigm and imply
you know lay it over your
older screenplay and it will show you
exactly why that script didn't work
it'll show you only two or three
interesting things happen in act one
you know well maybe only three or four
interesting things happened in act two
no that's not enough
um
i think that's
you're finally off the hook you know
okay you're right see you survived
um
thank you for your patience
through glitches and all
uh and allowing me to get through this i
know it was a lot to uh
to sit through um
questions
any questions uh we're gonna take a
break you finally get to go to the
bathroom
and uh and when you come back it'll be
just us and and and we can relax a bit
and talk about some of this stuff and
any questions you want to throw out
um have at me
okay
so thanks break time